hi my name is pedram mocrine i'm an
adjunct professor here at stanford
school of engineering
this course is designed for people that
are looking to get a better perspective
on what exactly ai is about and
demystify some of these notions in terms
of what is machine learning how is it
different from ai what are some of the
applications where is the future going
we're going to begin with taking a
historical view of ai a very
high level view of the technologies how
are we actually applying this ai
infrastructure and advancements in the
technology that we're getting into
business outcomes we're going to try to
bring this all together by giving you an
idea of how to think more strategically
about how do you actually put in place
an ai strategy as part of an existing
product or actually creating an entirely
new product line or service line that's
centered around ai
joining me are going to be a myriad of
folks that are coming from industry
themselves with a depth of background
and artificial intelligence that is
world-class you have large amounts of
data that these machines will be able to
give in our guidance run through very
quickly
find the patterns find the signals and
start to create potentially either
better products for you or new products
for you and that's really what's driving
almost all of the
the data-driven business strategies now
is is going out and getting data
rather than commodity analytics town
we've built a lot of infrastructure
whether by technology or by policy in
order to manage just the data aspect of
it before we even start looking at it
from an ai algorithm what can we learn
from a perspective
so we're really really excited to be
able to share some of these insights
with you and we're excited to get this
course underway
[Music]